Oh
the universe is unfathomably huge it's
so huge that it would take somewhere
around 70,000 years just to reach our
nearest neighboring star Proxima
Centauri which sits just 4.24
light-years away when you consider how
long it would take us to make that
relatively short trip it really helps to
show just how unreachable the farthest
points of space are measures not in tens
of light-years or hundreds or thousands
not even millions but distance is
measured in billions and billions of
light-years the unknown depths of space
are far beyond the reach of our current
technology so it stands to reason that
there are scores of discoveries just
waiting to be made out among the stars
one such potential discovery could
rewrite the laws of physics as we know
them if you've seen the show Rick and
Morty you're familiar with the idea of
multiple universes existing at the same
time scientists may have recently
discovered evidence for just that but
before we get started and speaking of
Rick and Morty I want to thank kwid for
sponsoring this video
Quaid is a new free app for iOS and
Android that lets you collect exclusive
stickers cards and figures right from
your phone use a lot of emojis when you
text your friends quit has thousands of
unique stickers that you can't find
anywhere else with sets from games like
fallout and five nights at freddys and
from shows like Game of Thrones Breaking
Bad Adventure Time and of course Rick
and Morty with QuIDD you can meet new
people trade stickers compare
collections and easily drag and drop
stickers into text messages opening
packs of stickers really brings me back
to the days of tearing into a new pack
of Pokemon cards as a kid and it's
seriously a lot of fun to build a
collection I personally find quit
tremendously useful when I need to
explain to somebody that their being a
Morty quit is available for iOS and the
beta version for Android to check out
the link in the description below to
download quit for free today now on with
the show this is a map of what's called
the cosmic microwave background or CMB
which is light that formed very early in
the life of our universe just 370
thousand years after the Big Bang the
blue and red dots represent minut
variations in temperature and therefore
density within the CMB indicating the
eventual birth of galaxies or empty
voids of space in 2004 astronomers
discovered something very strange
one of these cold spots located in the
constellation arisen as' is nearly a
hundred times cooler than the others and
much larger covering an expanse one
thousand times larger than the Milky Way
this spot was originally thought to be
an optical illusion caused by gravity
and a large void affecting light in the
foreground in 2015 when researchers from
the University of Hawaii attempted to
find evidence for such a void they came
away with the conclusion that there was
perhaps a small one but nothing
significant enough to explain the cold
spot according to Tom shanks of the
University of Durham
if this giant cold spot is not some
statistical fluctuation then the next
most standard explanation would be the
bubble universe collision hypothesis
this hypothesis suggests that our
universe and many others exist
simultaneously in a multi-dimensional
space like individual bubbles in a glass
of champagne every once in a while two
of these universes can collide with each
other sending a wave of energy through
our universe which would leave a
noticeable temperature bruise on the CMB
Mathew Cleavon an astronomer at NYU has
created detailed predictions of these
collisions and says if you had something
like one of these cosmic weeks which is
a kind of ripple that cuts across the
universe at that time you'll see a
particular pattern in the sky and he
suspects that this pattern would look
something like the mysterious cold spot
if the cold spot does turn out to be
solid evidence for a collision with
another universe what would that mean
one of the most important changes would
be the fact that we could possibly never
reach the ultimate goal of physics to
explain why the universe is the way it
is
if the multiverse is real then all of
our understanding of physics the speed
of light the strength of gravity
everything is arbitrary the universe
that collided with ours could operate
under an entirely different set of
physical laws every single possible
combination of variables would exist
somewhere in some other universe
floating in excessively in our bizarre
champagne glass to some people this may
seem depressing and might look like it
defeats the purpose of pursuing the
field of physics while it's true that
the existence of a multiverse would
render most of our scientific
understanding obsolete we have to
remember that Nature doesn't care about
our goals or aspirations humans have
existed for not even a blink of an eye
on a cosmic timescale the fact that
we're even here
unable to determine some of the nature
of the universe is a miraculous thing so
while the existence of another universe
may seem like a slap in the face to our
understanding of the natural world we
can take it as a new challenge for the
next generation of scientists and
astronomers and who knows maybe over the
course of the coming years will not only
be able to prove that other universes
exist but also come to understand them
and if we're really lucky maybe one day
we'll even get to send a probe to
explore these strange new frontiers and
make discoveries that would be
impossible in our home universe with
scientists actively investigating the
cold spot we could see evidence for or
against a bubble universe collision
within a year so regardless of the
outcome hopefully we won't have long to
wait of course if there are other
universes out there there's at least one
where we've already discovered them if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe to keep up to date with the
latest content and click the little bell
next to my channel name to be notified
every time I upload a new video you can
watch my previous video by clicking here
or if you're really bored you can watch
all my videos by clicking here thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video